Italy has lost more people to
coronavirus than any other country in
the world their individual names risk
being overlooked lost in the
ever-changing statistics of this
pandemic but at noon in cities and towns
across Italy every single one of them
was remembered local mayors stood on the
steps of their town halls in a minute's
silence it was an emotional gesture of
solidarity an expression of tribute and
an indication of hope all the mayor's
have gathered together in a kind of hug
most importantly near the places that
are suffering the most where the virus
has been strong least near the grief for
people who have died it is a sign of
respect to their families and their
small or big communities we are giving a
message of hope in the Bleak Madrid rain
Spain's gravediggers are going about
their task with grim purpose the virus
claimed another 849 lives here in the
previous 24 hours lockdown means the
burials are lonely and heartbreakingly
brief efforts to combat the virus and
save as many lives as possible increase
by the day this conference center in
Madrid one of several such venues across
Europe being converted to ease the
pressure on overcrowded hospitals the
French president has visited a face mask
factory in western France shortages of
masks and protective gowns have left
medical staff exposed to the virus with
the global market struggling to meet
demand
the president wants self-sufficiency
ironic season no poor vision or force
before the crisis we were producing 3.3
million mass per week by the end of
April it will be more than 10 million
meaning we have tripled our production
in just a few weeks and we will continue
these efforts to increase our production
capacity so that by the end of the year
we will have full independence in
producing the masks and not need to rely
on other countries the virus is also
proving a challenge to the European
Union's democratic principals on Monday
the Hungarian Parliament granted Prime
Minister Viktor Orban sweeping emergency
powers to rule by decree without any
time limit in Brussels on Tuesday the
Europe
Commission President Ursula Van der
Leyen expressed grave concern in a
statement read out by her spokesman any
emergency measures must be limited to
what is necessary and strictly
proportionate they must not last
indefinitely
moreover governments must make sure that
such measures are subject to regular
scrutiny coronavirus has changed what
might be considered normal there is
nothing normal about Europe streets
being deserted about shops being closed
about millions staying at home one day
tourists will return to the tourists a
fishery and enjoy the panorama across
Paris to the Eiffel Tower for now though
the disinfecting squads barely glanced
at the view in the effort to combat the
virus there is no such time to waste
Paul Brennan al Jazeera well we have
reporters following the story across
Europe in a moment we'll speak to
Francesco gamba Tony who's in Milan but
first let's talk to Marta Adaro in
Madrid in Spain and Marta the figures
are I'm afraid bleak do you fill us in
on the latest yes we see the evolution
of the number of infections in Spain in
the past three days we went from a 13.7
percent down to 19.3% it was just
yesterday but today figures have changed
and we have 9,000 200 new cases of
corona virus out of 94 thousand cases of
people that have tested tested positive
positive of copy 19 the death toll today
has reached 8100 with again over 800
people 849 more dead and this is the the
worst daily total so far have ministry
authorities say that the the upturn in
these today's figures might be due to
the weakened effect but people are not
very I'm not relying on that because so
everything is very very uncertain right
and resources of course because of that
getting stretched and stretched more and
more by the day but there is news I
understand of new equipment arriving
from overseas
yes yesterday and today we have have
been receiving planes with a lot of
equipment from China with receive mass
ventilators and this might help a little
bit to the health care workers that in
Spain right now represent around two
thirteen fourteen percent of the total
of people infected but from copy 19 in
in Spain so these people are in a very
vulnerable situation they're battling
against coronavirus in the hospitals and
they haven't got the proper equipment
they don't have any kind of safety
conditions in order to attend all these
patients they even have nurses and
doctors even have symptoms and there are
no test kits available for them to know
if they're positive or not they're still
go to the hospitals they still go back
home and the group is spreading the
corona virus so the situation for them
is really vulnerable they have been
struggling they have been calling uh
claiming the the government to supply
immediately all the all the material or
the equipment they need and hopefully it
starts that we start getting a little
bit of a but but still they have to
deliver it to the rest of the country
they have to deliver it nationwide so
they're we're better but we don't know
still how good we are so these people
the doctors and nurses we always pay
tribute to them at 8 o clock at 18:00
GMT we pay a tree would we go out to the
balconies to the windows we start
clapping aw one goes out to the windows
even the police that are in the city
trying to - to control the lockdown they
put the sirens on so we pay a tribute
but they are saying they don't want to
be heroes they don't want to be martyrs
anymore they just want to develop the
work in proper conditions and the
conditions they are doing their work
right now it's terrible hospitals are
overwhelmed emergency units cannot cope
anymore they're starting to think about
the possibility of transporting patients
from from one region of Spain to the
other Madrid has become the epicenter of
the pandemic since it's in the out since
the outbreak of corona virus and they
cannot cope anymore we've seen how the
army Stearn transporting corpses
yesterday transported 124 corpses to
this ice rink
set up as a funeral home so the
situation in Spain is really really grim
it's only is matter
thanks very much anyway for that update
Amato Adaro talking to us from Madrid
let's move on to Italy we can get more
on what's happening there we can speak
to Francesco Ziemba Tony who's in Milan
and Francesco Italy of course the
hardest-hit country in the world and we
have yet another huge death toll yes the
new figures anywhere a stabilized trend
in the country at least 837 people died
today it's a little bit more than
yesterday the total death toll is now
over twelve thousand four hundred the
confirmed positive cases are more than
one hundred five thousand but the growth
is much slower than last week that's the
good news
and the recovered have never been so
many so they they are now almost 16,000
there is a glimmer of hope according to
the latest forecasts based on different
researches Italy could reach to pick in
seven to ten days and see the new cases
hitting the zero in the first half of
May but as you can imagine we're not
even in April yet so it's a very long
way to go
and Francesca away from the intense
pressures on the hospitals and the
health workers and so forth is a intense
pressure on individuals around the
countries it's struggling to deal with
this the the worry and the fear of
contagion and so forth yeah not just
here in Lombardi but especially here
because here the lockdown has started
three days before the national lockdown
so a new law decree expected in a couple
of days will probably extend the
measures in the whole country up to the
80th of April so for two weeks more the
public opinion is wondering now what's
next it's been 21 days since the
beginning of the national lockdown and
it's not clear if the government is
working on any other plan than the
restrictions of movement and the
supports of the health system that of
course is is much needed now but the
authorities know that social isolation
is challenging dementia resistance of
Italians that's why the regions are
offering free services of psychological
health support now and the interior
ministry has also allowed parents to
take children for short walks close to
home because this situation is starting
to be really unsustainable the national
TV and radio channels would broadcast
tonight a big concert sort of Live Aid
with musicians playing and singing from
their homes of course not all together
with the aim of raising funds for the
health system and to relieve the
troubles of the people stuck at home
right rallying to the calls they're in
Italy Francesca is young but Tony we do
appreciate that thanks very much
let speak now to Marchetti who is
president of the Polly clinical hospital
in Milan he says they've been building
as Leeds largest intensive care facility
dedicated to treaty about 200
coronavirus patients it's not a proper
field hospital it's a real proper
Hospital that will hold up to two
hundred and eight persons it will it has
been built in the city of Milan with a
great effort of our region Lombardi and
it's in the pavilion of Milano fair and
we will take care of this of the new
hospital in town and it would be the
most the biggest intensive care Pavilion
in Italy and we've been under really
really high pressure until ten days ago
when this hospital was thought and so we
began to built it in ten days we have
did all this 53 first places in a real
hospital as I said before and you can
imagine any Lombardi we have more than
six
thousand and five hundred deaths and
41,000 people infected